DEATH PENALTY.
MIKE.
>> Mike: JACKIE, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
DOWN IN TEXAS, TWO PEOPLE WERE
KILLED BY THE GOVERNMENT DURING
A CHURCH SERVICE AND THE
ATTACKER WAS THEN SHOT AND THEN
KILLED BY MEMBERS OF THE
CONGREGATION.
CORRESPONDENT JEFF LOOKS AT THE
DEADLY ASSAULT THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN MUCH WORSE.
>> IT WAS OVER AND SIX SECONDS.
BUT WHAT HAPPENS IN THE BRIEF
MOMENT WILL NOW LAST A LIFETIME
FOR THE MEMBERS OF A NORTH TEXAS
CHURCH AND THE FAMILIES WHO LOST
LOVED ONES.
>> TO HAVE SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPEN DESTROYS MY HEART.
WHEN I SAY DESTROYS, IT DESTROYS
BECAUSE THERE IS EVIL IN THIS
WORLD.
>> WHEN THIS ESSAY SHOOTER WAS
WEARING A WIG AND FAKE.
PERIOD.
THAT'S WHEN HE GOT UP AND SHOT
THOUGH MIKE PULLED A SHOTGUN.
>> HE STARTED SHOOTING.
>> THE SUSPECT SHOTS ULTIMATELY
LEFT TWO DEAD AND CHURCH MEMBERS
IDENTIFIED THE VICTIMS AS OF
VICTOR AND RICHARD.
HE PULLED OUT HIS OWN GUN
KILLING THE SUSPECT.
>> I DON'T SEE MYSELF AS A HERO,
I SEE MYSELF AS DOING WHAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE TO TAKE OUT
THE EVIL THREAT.
>> 2019 LAW IN TEXAS ALLOWED
LICENSE GUN HOLDERS TO CARRY IN
PLACES OF WORSHIP ONLY IF IT'S
NOT SPECIFICALLY BANNED BY A
CHURCH.
I DIFFERENT LAW PASSED TWO YEARS
PRIOR IN THE STATE ALSO GIVES
CHURCHES THE RIGHT TO HAVE ARMED
THE VOLUNTEER SECURITY.
>> WE HAVE LAWS AGAINST MURDER
AND IT DIDN'T STOP THIS GUY.
I'M COMING IN AND
I'M COMING IN KND
I'M COMING IN KILLING PEOPLE.
TEXAS CAN GET YOU THE DEATH
PENALTY GREETING MORE GUN LAWS
IS NOT GOING TO CHANGE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS.
>> WHILE THOSE WHO WATCH THE
HORROR UNFOLD TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY SAW AND
WHY, SOME ALREADY ARE FINDING
FORGIVENESS.
>> IT WAS A BAD THING HE HAD TO
COME INTO THE CONGREGATION AND
IS A SAD THING WE HAD TO HURT
HIM.
BUT, I DON'T HAVE ANY HATE FOR
THIS PERSON.
>> AUTHORITIES SAY THE SHOOTER
HAD TIES IN THE DALLAS-FORT
WORTH AREA AND MULTIPLE ARRESTS